at approximately 7 45 a.m houston police
were contacted about an aggravated
robbery in southwest houston where a
chevy tahoe was stolen at gunpoint a k-9
unit officer spotted the vehicle and
attempted a traffic stop the suspect
failed to stop and a pursuit ensued
hpd officers from northeast patrol
joined the pursuit which ended at 7 800
tidwell
there mr marcelo alfredo suarez drove
the stolen suv onto a median
mr suarez exited the vehicle and
attempted to flee on foot
k-9 officer nate and three other
officers gave pursuit while running mr
swatis turned and fired a gun toward the
officers
three officers then discharged their
duty weapons striking mr suarez
officers rendered medical aid before ems
arrived to transport mr suarez to the
hospital where he later succumbed to his
injuries
one officer sustained a minor injury
get on the ground on the ground now hey
down down down down here's that knife
loose
loose
good nice both both face first first
first fruits
all right we're good we're good all
right everybody's calm down
everybody check yourself everybody check
yourself everybody do it
everybody good
all right look hey hold on hold on rifle
first me and canine okay
just hold the air please hold the air
it's closed go ahead
and you're good to go slow down slow
down everybody slow down hey peel off to
my right please take the take the metal
barrier
[Music]
all right take your time take your time
everybody good okay put your hands out
if you can hear me do not move do not
move all right gun's right here on the
right guns right here on the right
you're not moving
stay back stay back
all right i'm gonna hey go ahead go
ahead he's secure
taking the gun okay
hey let's leave it are you good with us
leaving here
[Music]
shots fired shots fired hold the air
suspects down suspect is down
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
hold here hold here
mike slow down take the metal barrier
he's moving still
going by
him
you're good tom take your time everybody
good you're good i'm good
if you can hear me do not move all right
i'll
[Music]
shots fire shots drop the gun drop that
gun
drop that gun
he's down
let's move up
okay hey everybody good everybody going
we're good let's move up slow
hold on rifle first me and canine okay
i'm listening give me some information
hold the air hold the air hold here move
up slow you drop the gun
he dropped the gun
let's just move up on him slow down hold
here over here
he's moving still
all right i see the gun next to him
take your time take your time
suspect put your hands out if you can
hear me do not move do not move all
right guns right here on the right all
right on the right do not move go back
straight
stay back
all right
all right he's secure he's secure thank
you okay k-19
we got the gun secure roll hfd for this
suspect
everybody good i'm good all right
cracked up cracked up in northwest side
until well
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
over here
[Music]
[Music]
right here on the right do not move
get back up stay down
all right i'm gonna all right
you're here taking the gun okay can i
see
[Music]
appreciate it